IRENE NOKAN: Well, hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
My name is Irene
[? Nokan ?], and I
am on the large customer sales
team out of San Francisco.
I'm here today to introduce
chef Jason Halverson, formerly
the sous chef of Michael Mina.
He is now the executive chef at
two San Francisco restaurants,
Stones Throw in Russian Hill
and Trestle in Jackson Square.
So please join me in
giving him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON HALVERSON: Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome.
Thank you for having us.
It's super exciting.
We're going to
make a pasta dish.
Pasta really makes me happy.
It's a fun dish that really just
includes things that I like.
And that's what's fun about
cooking for me, where you can
include things that you like.
If you like something,
you add more of it.
If you don't like
something, keep it
out of there, which
makes it really fun.
So what we're making is
a squid ink coquille.
So coquille being the
shape of the pasta.
Squid ink being the
base or the flavor
or the coloring of
what we're making.
But to start we're
going to make the sauce.
So the sauce itself is a
shellfish and caper sauce.
It's slightly spicy.
The whole dish is
slightly spicy.
There's a lot of acid.
It's really, slightly rich,
which makes it a lot of fun.
So to start in a pan, one
thing that we've done already
is we've cut off
mussels and clams.
If anybody hasn't ever cooked
mussels and clams, what
we really did is we're
using it for the juice.
And we're going to use the
clams and mussels later.
But basically we had
a pan get really hot.
We added the mussels and
the clams, covered them
in white wine, covered
the pot, and what
happens is they'll
steam opened letting out
a lot of their liquid, which
is a great base for a sauce.
Which you'll see how we
use it here in a second.
So trying to figure out how
to use this fancy stove.
So what we have-- a smaller
pot, a little bit of oil.
What we're going to do
is to the base of this,
start by sweating
out some onions.
We're going to try to
make these translucent.
You'll see, I guess in
my style of cooking,
onions are used as a
base for a lot of things.
It's just a great foundation.
We'll get a lot of nice
flavor out of this.
I also like how they
smell, which is weird.
So we'll let that
kind of start off.
Other ingredients in the
sauce itself are capers.
Capers for me add a
saltiness, which I really
like, without adding just a
handful or big pinch of salt.
It actually adds a flavor, which
has its own again, salinity.
We'll have sliced garlic.
Again, the spicy component
to it is a piri piri chili.
It's pretty spicy.
It's a North African chili.
This one happens to be dried.
If for any reason
you can't find these,
a chili flake is a
great substitution.
What's fun again,
about this is if you're
a fan of something spicy,
go ahead, get crazy with it,
use a lot.
But if you're kind of
timid about it, shy away.
It's kind of making
what you want.
What we're going to do is
add some sliced garlic.
And more or less
seeing fit to you.
We're going to take a
couple of these piri piris.
If you use these, make sure
to wash your hands after.
Don't touch your face,
don't do anything else,
just wash your hands.
And with these, I'm
just about adding
or I'm going to add
four or five of these.
You can always add more,
it's hard to take it away,
so kind of a fun note with that.
Capers.
Capers themselves are going
to be the main salt component,
so I actually enjoy quite
a few of that in there.
And pretty soon you should be
able to start smelling this.
IRENE NOKAN: How do
you go about finding
quality shellfish like the
ones you're using here today?
JASON HALVERSON:
There's a lot of trust
that we have like
fish purveyors.
And you kind of just build this
trust on what they're getting
and who they're getting it from.
And it's kind of like
a bad relationship
where you always want
to trust that they're
going to get you the best.
And they usually
do, but those times
where if you run into
somebody that gives you just
bad shellfish, it's really bad.
Stay away from it.
I tend not to try
to use them anymore.
So as you guys can see, or I
don't know if you guys can see,
it's really starting
just to cook really fast.
The onions are translucent,
the garlic has a smell.
Next thing, we have a
little extra white wine.
So white wine, you really want
something that's not sweet.
I like acid wines.
You're starting to look at even
the style of like a Chardonnay
or Sauvignon Blanc,
those kind of things.
Again, just kind of trying
to stay away from sweetness.
And what you're
going to let this do
is now come up to a boil.
Really what you're trying to do
is burn out that raw alcohol.
All right.
You're going to get that
flavor, you may get drunk,
I don't know.
But the idea is just to
burn out that alcohol.
So that's up to a boil now.
The last thing we're
going to add to this sauce
before we start on
the rest of it again,
is all the liquor from
cooking the mussels and clams.
When you're cooking your
mussels and clams again,
save the juice.
It's really good.
One thing you want to do is,
before you cook your shellfish,
try to soak it in water.
Or let them kind of purge
out any extra sediment
that's in there.
Otherwise you're going to end
up with something really gritty.
And after that, after
we cook it, we also
strain it again just to
make sure there's no grit.
So I'll add that in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON HALVERSON: What was that?
AUDIENCE: What did you add
to cook in [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON HALVERSON: Just the
wine, or just the same wine
that we used for the sauce.
AUDIENCE: Was there any water?
JASON HALVERSON: No water.
Water acts for me
like it's always
great to have and use
when you're cooking.
It's kind of that,
it dilutes flavors.
So you're going to have to
cook something a little bit
longer just to make that happen.
So again, literally, we're going
to let this come up to a boil.
We'll turn it down.
You just really want to let
these flavors come together.
It takes about 10, 15 minutes
in a batch about this size.
So give it a taste and make
sure it's what you want.
The next thing we're going
to make is the pasta.
So anybody ever made pasta?
Anybody?
Yeah?
A lot of fun.
I love making pasta.
The pasta we're going
to make, no eggs.
OK.
So really kind of a hand
rolled style pasta dough.
What we have here in the
bowl, two different flours.
We have Double 00 flour
and Extra Fancy Durum.
So the combination,
what you'll see,
just makes for a different
texture of pasta.
We like this one really
dense, because what
happens when you cook it,
especially in the sauce,
it starts to absorb the sauce.
Just kind of making
things taste better.
With that what we have here
is a combination of water,
just like we talked
about, and squid ink.
Squid ink, not a lot of
flavor necessarily in it.
You're not gonna necessarily
get this super brininess,
but you definitely
get this color,
which kind of associate with.
More so just going to
add all these together.
IRENE NOKAN: Is
there a reason why
you prefer to add the
squid ink with the pasta
versus in the sauce?
JASON HALVERSON: I like,
that's a great question.
First and foremost,
when I'm eating it,
I've had bad experiences
where I eat it as a sauce,
and then for some reason I
smile and I have black teeth.
Not so hot.
It gets kind of weird.
I look like that
guy, which is no fun.
So it actually kind of helps
tame the whole I guess,
identity of the squid ink.
So I'm going to
kind of cheat here.
We're going to use
the KitchenAid.
We're going to start
with the paddle.
I don't know if you
guys can see it.
More so just to kind of
bring the dough together.
IRENE NOKAN: And for
those who don't know,
what is Double 00 flour,
and where can you get that?
JASON HALVERSON: You can get
it, most of these ingredients
you'll be able to find really
easily at a Whole Foods readily
available.
It's an extra milled flour.
Its has a different gluten
and different absorption
rate than something
like an AP flour.
You can absolutely
make it with that,
this just helps with
again, the textures,
the density, things like that.
So let's see if I can't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON HALVERSON: I've also
found it at a Whole Foods.
Obviously we have our
own purveyor for it,
but for the small amounts,
instead of buying a huge jar,
I've definitely seen it
at a Whole Foods for sure.
IRENE NOKAN: And for those
who didn't hear the question,
it was where do you
source the squid ink.
JASON HALVERSON:
Hand that to you.
This is great.
In case you guys are wondering,
this is Ryan over here.
He usually tells me what to
do, so this is kind of nice.
IRENE NOKAN: Is he with
you in the kitchen, too?
JASON HALVERSON: He's usually
yelling at me in the kitchen.
IRENE NOKAN: Yeah?
JASON HALVERSON: But, so
really what's going to happen
here is this dough's
going to come together.
If anybody, again,
has made dough--
I'm going to try to
churn it somehow,
I'm looking at the
screen back there--
usually a dough will
come together really
fast with this one with no egg.
You really actually want
it as dry as possible.
It becomes really difficult to
work with when it's super dry,
but the outcome is way better.
Obviously if you
add too much water,
it just becomes really
elasticky and kind of a mess.
What's fun about these pastas
is they hold their shape really
well when the texture's right.
So that's kind of what
we're looking for.
So this is actually going
to take a little while.
It will come together.
That's what it does.
But to kind of move
with it, what we've done
is actually made
the pasta itself.
It's a nice big
black sheet of pasta.
Started this week,
we're fortunate to have
a pasta machine,
which makes working
with pasta a little bit easier.
And what we've done, we've just
rolled it out into a sheet.
So rolled out to say, just
over an eighth of an inch.
And what we do is we
just cut little squares.
It's fun.
One of the reasons
I like making pasta
is there are so many different
shapes you can kind of go with.
Even if it's not really a
shape, you made it yourself,
so it's kind of cool.
It's organic.
So just cutting
into little squares.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to use
a little gnocchi
board to kind of
make a shape, which
you can find at most places.
William Sonoma, Sur la Table,
Amazon, all those places
you can find them.
As you guys can tell, this one's
been used just a little bit,
makes a lot of pasta.
You get a lot of ridges.
You get ridges out of this,
you can start to make shapes.
So what we do is with that
being somewhat of a square,
we'll aim at rolling
from corner to corner.
So what you're going
to do is push and kind
of roll, which is
fun for the shape.
So push and roll.
And that's kind of
what you end up with.
I got lucky on that one.
IRENE NOKAN: You made
that look fancy so fast.
JASON HALVERSON: I did.
I got lucky.
So really again, you can
make all sorts of shapes.
If it comes to being where
you don't have one of these,
it's not going to
be something where
you can't make this pasta.
If you have a counter, which
I hope most of you guys do,
you're making the pasta somehow,
roll it straight on the board.
You're not gonna
really lose much.
It's just kind of fun.
Really just kind of build, I
guess, your repertoire of pasta
making.
AUDIENCE: Use a fork.
JASON HALVERSON: Use a fork.
Absolutely.
If you guys didn't hear, the
suggestion was to use a fork.
Italian grandmothers use forks.
I love Italian grandmothers,
and they make really good pasta.
So absolutely go for it.
But that's what you can do.
What's fun is in the
case of what you'll
see with this dish is if you're
going to have friends over,
you can make most of
this dish all in advance.
It becomes really easy.
Almost feel like a
Sara Lee or someone
like that trying to tell
you guys how to do this.
But feel free to make the pasta
head and just to be ready.
So with this pasta, we'll have
a pot of boiling water, which
we don't have set up here.
We made pasta already.
Make sure it's up to a boil,
lightly seasoned with salt.
And the reason I
say lightly seasoned
is because the sauce itself
is going to have salt. Again,
you can always
add salt, you just
don't want to hit that point
of something being salty.
You'll boil it for
about three minutes.
You'll still have a little
bit, it'll be al dente.
You'll still have a
little bit of a bite.
Just kind of adding to the
right texture for this dish, so
basically, after you're
done blanching the pasta.
See where we're at here.
This is what it looks like.
It's going to be a
nice, sturdy pasta.
It's really, it's what it is.
We'll start that.
Get this out of the way.
Again, being a shellfish
pasta, what we're going to do
is I'm going to show you guys
all the seafoods that we use.
I love seafood.
Anybody here
allergic to seafood?
I hope not.
Might not like me.
So again, to start
mussels and clams,
we cooked them in white wine.
This is exactly what
we use for the sauce.
Chef Deedee back
there actually did
a great job of cooking the
pasta or the shellfish.
Thank you for doing that.
Appreciate it.
So again, it's covered or a
hot pan, all the shellfish,
white wine is covered.
You're going to wait
until they open.
That's it.
They're ready to
go at that point.
After that, we separated
it from the liquid,
and all we're going to do is
take them out of the shell.
If they're not open, don't
try to fight them open.
If everything else
is open, don't
try to break them
open to get it out.
That's not necessarily a good
sign of a good shellfish.
So that was the mussels.
The clams, the exact same thing.
Just kind of pulling
these guys out.
There you go.
So we have that.
Don't know why I did
this, but everything can
kind of go in the same bowl.
It's all going to go in
the same place anyways.
So then after that
we have our calamari.
I love calamari.
I can eat it fried,
baked, fried again.
Love the stuff.
And again with this,
make it as you see fit.
With this we're going
to just do rings.
It's pretty straightforward,
just cutting straight across.
Nothing fancy with this.
You can absolutely get fancy.
Again, another way, too, if you
don't have calamari, calamari
steak, you know what I mean.
The possibilities
are pretty endless.
Kind of based on what you
have, what you want to eat.
We've done this version of a,
or this dish with a version
of lobster before.
That was super fancy,
especially for pasta.
And we'll do one more.
Just make-- oh, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON HALVERSON: We usually do.
They're fun to throw in there.
They're just kind of waving
all around, which is fun,
but just in this instance,
we don't happen to have them.
So another one of my
favorites, shrimp.
I love shrimp.
We won't even talk about
fried or anything again.
That's a given.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
JASON HALVERSON: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
about your restaurants.
So you've got a couple.
What's the difference?
JASON HALVERSON: Oh.
Ryan, you want to
take that one over?
RYAN: Sure.
This is perfect.
I don't know how many of
people have been up to the city
or been to Stones Throw.
Stones Throw was our
first restaurant.
When we both were at Michael
Mina and different situations
in the past, we decided
to go open that.
Think of it if you took a
Michael Mina style restaurant
and plopped it into
a neighborhood.
A little more affordable,
not as complicated,
a lot more comfortable
in the style
of environment and service.
Had that for about
a year and a half,
and then decided to open
a second restaurant.
So Trestle has been open
for maybe four months now.
Completely shifted
directions on that,
and that is a prefix
three course menu for $35.
It's the only thing
we offer where
you get a choice between
two items on each course.
You can add a pasta
course if you want
for $10, but the similar style.
I mean, his food,
it's got a style.
You will recognize if you come
to one or the other restaurant,
there is a stylistic
similarity between the two.
Stones Throw affords us a little
more complexity in dishes.
We have more staff.
We have more space,
a larger menu,
so we can do things that are
a little more complicated.
Also the price difference
helps when you charge $35,
you're kind of a little
restricted in what you can do.
But you'll see the
same thought process
behind the food, service,
the experience at both spots.
And we're opening
another restaurant
at the end of the year.
So we're staying busy.
JASON HALVERSON: Yeah!
IRENE NOKAN: Exciting.
AUDIENCE: What's the concept
of the third restaurant?
[INAUDIBLE]
RYAN: Interesting question.
We're sharing-- oh.
The question is
what's the concept
of the third restaurant.
We're sharing high
level details.
Yes.
So it's at the 100 Van
Ness building, which used
to be the old AAA headquarters.
It's on the corner of
Van Ness and Hayes.
Almost like right next
to Vanessa and Market.
And we're doing two
concepts in there.
One is going to be a
cafe and a sandwich shop.
So we're partnering
with a coffee roaster
from Los Angeles called LAMILL,
doing an interesting coffee
program, tea program, and then
kind of artisinal sandwiches.
We've been running one of
them on UberEATS, actually.
Just recently we do a
chicken parm sandwich.
That's pretty awesome.
And then the other
is going to be
kind of a hybrid between fine
dining and fast casual service.
It's no reservations.
There's some interesting
tech components
we're trying to put into it.
And you should get
the feel like you're
in one of our restaurants,
but without the same sequence
of service in a
two hour setting.
You should be able
to get in and out,
you're in the
theater area, you're
next to the civic center.
So that's the general
gist of where it's going.
Probably in a few weeks, we'll
announce a little bit more.
JASON HALVERSON:
I like your style.
IRENE NOKAN: I remember
reading that there
was a sort of charity
component to Stones Throw
that you were encouraging
patrons to come and bring
canned food in.
Do you still do that?
RYAN: We do, so-- are you ready
to keep going with the dish?
I don't want to--
JASON HALVERSON: Keep going.
RYAN: So, yeah, so from
kind of month two on when
we started Stones Throw,
he and I got together
and we talked about it.
We really want to do a
charitable event or component,
so we do what we call Eat Like
a Chef, Drink Like a Song.
So since February
of 2014, every month
we invite a guest
chef to come in,
and we do a five course
tasting menu the last Monday
of every month.
We do half the menu,
they do half the menu.
And all the proceeds
go to a charity.
We pick one charity per year.
So last year it
was the food bank,
this year we chose Ronnie
Lott's All Stars Helping Kids.
And then we kind of
evolved from there
with Ronnie Lott being on board.
I'm hoping most of you
know who Ronnie Lott is.
Hall of Fame, 49er, Super
Bowl hero, et cetera.
JASON HALVERSON: Yeah, for sure.
RYAN: Cut off a finger in a game
to win a Super Bowl, et cetera.
We've kind of introduced
athletes into the mix.
So we had last
month was Boulevard
was the guest restaurant, Joe
Montana was to guest athlete.
And the idea behind
the event is it's
designed for people like us.
It's younger
professionals who don't
want to go to a gala
dinner, who don't
want to spend $500 a plate.
And the idea was we can
teach the next generation how
to give back by saying, you
can come for $60 a person,
have a five course dinner.
Whereas, if you go anywhere
else in San Francisco for dinner
like I did last night, you'll
spend way more than $60.
And here all the money
goes to the charity.
So year to date, this year we've
already donated through $30,000
just from doing eight events
or nine events for it.
And we have two more
up coming, so if you're
looking for an
interesting event,
this month is Kim Alter from
Dana Patterson's group Plum
Haven.
She's opening a new
project on her own.
And then Michael
Mina is actually
doing the one in November to
finish up the year for us.
IRENE NOKAN: Great.
Thank you.
JASON HALVERSON: Super exciting.
It's a lot of fun.
So back into the dish right now.
We've gotten to the point
where we're basically ready.
Let's sample the whole thing.
If you were going to do this
for a party, you're ready to go.
You ready to cook for your
friends without sweating a lot,
which is nice.
And we'll kind of just bring
it all back together just
to make sure that
we're all there.
So try to make sure
this is the right place.
So again we've made the sauce,
we have pasta, it's blanched.
It's ready to go.
All the shellfishes that we
want, love, ready to eat.
The same piri piris,
we're just going to kind
of refortify that flavor.
The more sliced garlic.
And you guys are
going to see what
we're going to deal with
that here in a second.
Touch of butter and lemon juice.
Lemon juice is going to just
clean the whole dish up.
You guys will see
here in a second.
And then the last one, which
we didn't really get to.
For me, pasta dishes can
become extremely heavy, very
kind of mundane to eat, I guess.
So one of the things
that I really love
is kind of a more
fresh component.
So what we have here is
what's called peacock kale.
We took out the stems, kind
of made small little bites out
of it.
What it does is it
lightly wilts, obviously.
With the greens,
you guys usually
want to cook them down and
maybe braise them however so.
This is light enough
or it's sturdy
enough to where it won't
just kind of break apart
and/or become a mess.
But it's also light
enough to where
it's like if you
lightly wilt it, give it
just a little bit of heat,
it's really pleasurable to eat.
It also holds like sauces and
things like that really well.
So hot pan is what we have here.
And add just a touch of oil.
A lot of people are actually
afraid to cook with oil.
Not in the sense of like afraid
I'm not going to use oil,
but usually the problem
with cooking at home
is people don't use like enough.
Not that you need to
fill the whole bottom,
but it definitely helps
in the cooking process.
So hopefully I'm
using this right.
So with the pan more so on
the higher side of heat,
slice garlic.
OK?
It has this nice sound, you know
you're doing something right.
And what we're going
to do is not quite,
we're not going to burn it,
but we're going to toast it.
And what that does is it's
going to add this kind of really
distinct flavor.
That's really kind of
just distinct, especially
to this day for us.
And for me that's kind of
like the way I like to cook.
You're trying to layer a lot of
flavors via what salty, what's
sweet in a dish, what's
the richness, what's
the acid component.
It's almost like
formula cooking,
but it's just the idea of how
do you balance out a dish.
So as you guys can
see, it's really
starting just to get brown now.
We're going to go just
a little bit longer.
Just kind of to
the point where you
don't want to necessarily
walk away from it.
IRENE NOKAN: Do you have
any go to ingredients
to elevate a dish's flavor?
Like, your favorite?
JASON HALVERSON: My
favorite, like honestly,
onions, as dumb as that sounds,
actually add a layer of flavor.
That's kind of just the most
apparent, that and shallots.
And then I'm a huge spice freak,
not in the sense of things
being spicy, but just spices
and spice blends and things
like that.
So what we've done is we've
added the shellfish or all
the sea food.
We're going to add in a
couple of our chilies.
Again, more so however
you want it to taste.
Again, you want it
spicy, get crazy.
Kind of breaking them in here.
Give that a stir.
Now we're going
to add our sauce.
Giving myself a
little steam bath.
We're going to add in our pasta.
Again, this is already cooked.
So now we're just looking
to kind of warm it through.
We're gonna add just,
everybody close your eyes
for two seconds, just a
just a touch of butter.
I'll save one in there.
You guys didn't close your eyes.
IRENE NOKAN: Why do you add
it at the end like that?
JASON HALVERSON: So what
you're going to try to do,
butter is fat, fat emulsifies.
So what we're
trying to do is make
this like a rich,
kind of glazy pasta,
which helps with the addition.
The sequence of
steps with it kind of
helps make its own sauce as
opposed to having a big pot
of like this creamy sauce.
You're kind of just making a
sauce in itself or in the pan.
They're adding
chilies back they're.
It's going to hit you guys
here in a few seconds,
so if this side starts
coughing, you guys are safe.
I promise.
If you guys really
take a look it's
like, before it was
just liquid, now it's
starting to have this viscosity.
One more chili.
Does everybody see that?
Now it's more of like a sauce in
here as opposed to just water.
Oh, it gotcha.
[LAUGHING]
Pinch of salt. Taste your food.
Make sure it's what you like.
AUDIENCE: Do you
need a taste tester?
IRENE NOKAN: Do you need--
[LAUGHING]
JASON HALVERSON: Always.
It's going to be good.
So the last two things
to go in to the point
where we're almost
there are going
to be the greens and, not
the cooking oil, lemon juice.
For me I add the kale first,
because I want to just give it
just a little bit to wilt down.
With the kale being raw,
I've already tasted it.
I know I just want
a touch more salt,
because of what the
flavor of this is.
This burner doesn't like that.
And as you guys
can notice again,
that starting just
to break down itself.
anybody's offended
by butter, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask,
so this, everyone keeps
saying it's very simple, but
when I think about making this
at home, I think, this is
more like a Saturday night
kind of dish, I think.
JASON HALVERSON: I like
your Saturday night.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Do you have
things, like kind
of go to favorites that you
make at home that are easy?
JASON HALVERSON: I'm super
simple when I'm at home.
Like for me, I love
roasted chicken,
as dumb as that sounds.
It's like the day you make
the perfect roasted chicken,
it's kind of that
oh, yeah, I'm going
to make it again and again.
I love simple foods.
I love one pot dishes.
Stew is my favorite.
Actually, kind of my go to,
two go tos in that style.
Anybody been to Olive Garden?
Cheesy, I love Olive Garden.
I make that soup all the time.
I'm a jerk.
I love that stuff.
It's potatoes, it's
sausage, it's kale,
it's rich, it's hearty,
like that kind of thing.
White bean stews, the
base to it is great,
whether you want to go
like chorizo and pekios,
or you want to go sausage
and lots of wine, who knows.
It's there, you know.
And that's kind of my
favorite part about cooking.
Got a bowl, by chance, chef?
Thank you.
IRENE NOKAN: Just to
add to that question,
for those of us
here in the room who
often have a lot of work
demands and family demands
and don't have a lot of
time to cook at home,
do you have any
recommendations or tips for how
to go about that more
efficiently so we can do it
in less time?
JASON HALVERSON: Hire me.
IRENE NOKAN: Hire you?
Oh, hey, all right.
JASON HALVERSON: For
me, I always love, it's
always fun to cook.
And so at the restaurants, we
do what's called family meal.
Family meal being the time
where everybody gets together.
It's right before service.
We cook dinner for
ourselves, basically.
The fun thing about
it is it's not
the idea ever of necessarily
cooking something that's
fresh that day.
The example of a
roasted chicken is hey,
we may take a roasted, a
bunch of roasted chickens.
You know what I mean?
It's the case.
Great, we have roasted chicken.
Let's eat.
I'm happy.
I'm excited.
We're not going to eat it all.
So what we did is
we just basically
prepped at that time
for the next day.
So if we pick the chicken after
that, it may be chicken soup.
You know what I mean?
Chicken and potato, chicken
and kale, chicken and beans,
I don't know.
Whatever anybody's excited for.
So that's kind of
how we like to cook.
I mean--
IRENE NOKAN: So maybe
you could do a big meal
like on Sunday, and--
JASON HALVERSON: Exactly.
IRENE NOKAN: --stretch it out.
IRENE NOKAN: The uses of
it, anyway, over the week.
JASON HALVERSON: So here are the
dishes done, lots of seafood.
This is for everybody
to share, just in case
you guys were wondering.
[LAUGHING]
IRENE NOKAN: I don't think
that's going to be enough.
[LAUGHING]
JASON HALVERSON:
But that right there
is just a fun bowl of pasta.
So that's it.
IRENE NOKAN: That looks so good.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON HALVERSON: You
can have the first one.
IRENE NOKAN: Oh, thanks.
Do we have time for questions?
JASON HALVERSON: Any questions.
IRENE NOKAN: Great.
Does anyone have any questions?
JASON HALVERSON: I'm
always scared of these.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: It's a good question.
I went to Stones
Throw a while ago,
and I remember fondly
that they had an option
to give a suggestion
for a dessert.
JASON HALVERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering
what came of that.
JASON HALVERSON:
So the question is,
or I guess, to
expand the question,
at Stones Throw what's really
fun is I have a pastry chef.
She's great, but what makes
it fun for people to come in
is our desserts.
And so our dessert program is
after you finish your dinner,
you can have dessert.
[LAUGHING] What we
do-- It's so scary.
What we do is we draw up a menu.
On the bottom of the menu, our
program is childhood favorites.
What was your favorite
childhood dessert?
Mine was like not
necessarily dessert,
but mine was peanut
butter and jelly.
I love peanut butter
and jelly, still do.
What we ask for is a suggestion.
What's your favorite
childhood dessert?
We ask for your e-mail
or your phone number.
We'll give you a
call if we choose it.
Come in, try it.
See what you think of our
rendition of a dessert.
So it's constantly evolving.
Part of it has to deal
with the season, part of it
has to deal with kind of just
what's going on at that time.
But if we choose
it, you come in.
You try it.
Hopefully, you kind
of relive a little bit
of a childhood, a little bit
of your childhood, I guess.
Current desserts right now
are peanut butter and jelly.
So we do vanilla, sugar,
[? Doucet ?] beignets.
We do it with a little bit of
candy peanuts, peanut cream,
Concord grape gel,
and chocolate cremu.
So the idea is really just
grab a donut, kind of get dirty
with it, and enjoy it.
Strawberry cheesecake is
one of them right now.
We have the blackberry crisp.
And again, these are
all kind of our version,
so it's not necessarily
going to be something
where you get a plate
and it's, oh, it's
a blackberry crisp, thanks.
Not necessarily that
straightforward,
but it makes it fun for us.
So it's always evolving.
We have 2,000 suggestions.
There's a lot of people
with a lot of suggestions,
which is fun.
But that's kind of what we do.
So anything else?
IRENE NOKAN: Do you have
a question right there?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about making the pasta,
because I saw during, when
you were making the pasta,
there were two different
hats that you choose.
What's the difference
between those
for like blending the
flour and the squid ink?
JASON HALVERSON: Say that again.
My apologies.
AUDIENCE: So I remember
during the presentation,
there was a time
that you changed
the head of the blender.
JASON HALVERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference between those two?
JASON HALVERSON: So
one was a paddle.
One is the dough hook itself.
So the paddle, the dough
hook there is really no,
there's nothing to it.
It's the hook.
It's going to grab something
that's already made
and move it around.
The paddle, itself,
the reason we
did that is because you have a
lot of raw ingredients, which
is going to help bring
them all together.
We got it to a certain
point where it's there,
or that it actually
started to come together.
And then you're going to
want to just kind of check
the moisture.
But as you can tell
it's dough now.
What we try to do
with the hook then
is use the hook to kind
of knead the dough.
Kind of starting all the
glutens and to make the dough
come together, to give
it some structure.
For this dough, it does
take a little while
to come together, which
makes the dough what it is.
If it was super, we could
add a ton of water in here,
it would come together
in two seconds.
But then you're going to have
this really soft pasta that's
more like an overcooked noodle
before you even cook it.
So that's kind of how
the two work together.
AUDIENCE: If you don't
have a KitchenAid,
is it very hard to
make your own pasta?
JASON HALVERSON: It's not.
It's more like a workout.
[LAUGHING]
I've actually worked in a
kitchen where I wasn't allowed
to use this, which was fun.
I got a really big right arm.
So no.
It's actually a
little bit more work.
You tend to, it just takes
a little bit more work.
That's it.
Anything done by hand,
honestly, kind of the motto
is it's going to take a little
more work no matter what.
So it's honestly a lot
of fun to make pasta
by hand, especially this style.
Again, with this, I think
you guys have the recipe
to the pasta dough.
If you want to make it or
you didn't have squid ink,
it's the exact same thing.
All you're doing is adding a
touch of water to this flour.
It's two ingredients,
flours and water.
And pretty straightforward
from there.
IRENE NOKAN: And can
you talk a little bit
about the advantages of fresh
pasta versus a dried pasta?
JASON HALVERSON: I'm
not biased either.
So fresh pasta,
we'll start here.
Dried pasta, generally,
we're buying it.
I don't have to make anything.
It's kind of nice.
What's really actually nice
about dry pastas for me is
there's a little bit
more time cooking.
So for me, if there is more
time to cook something,
I get to do a little bit more
in terms of flavor and texture.
And you're going to notice
those kind of things.
So if I had grandma's
tomato sauce,
I might cook the dried pasta for
a little while 3/4 of the time
that it's supposed
to say on the box.
I might take and add
in some grandma's sauce
and use that to cook it more.
All of a sudden, my
pasta has absorbed
more of that sauce as opposed
to water, butter, and cheese.
So that's kind of
one huge aspect.
With fresh pasta, you
can manipulate it more so
in the style of what it is.
Sheets, raviolis, things
like that, you can't really
do that with a dried pasta.
So there's a lot of things.
It's really kind of
just due to the scenario
in which you're in.
IRENE NOKAN: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I guess going
off with that question.
So there are still called fresh
pasta from grocery stores.
What's the difference
between those fresh pastas
versus if we make them at home?
JASON HALVERSON:
One costs you $6.99,
and the other one
costs you nothing.
It's the same process.
They're really just doing
it in the industrial size.
Honestly, there are some
great products out there.
People have making stuff.
What's fun, I think,
nowadays, there's
kind of the market for
people wanting the example
to cook a great meal.
You know what I mean?
They don't have the
capacity necessarily
to make everything from
scratch themselves.
And so you have this market that
people are putting their heart
into a product for you.
So if you like to do that,
take advantage of that.
Have a good time.
It makes cooking a
little bit more fun
and a touch more desirable
when you're not having
to stress about everything.
Like, hey, if I go buy
a fresh sheet of pasta
and I want to make raviolis,
all the power to you.
Have fun with it.
IRENE NOKAN: All right.
Well, thank you, again, Chef
Jason Halverson for joining us.
Hope to see you again here, too.
JASON HALVERSON:
Thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE]